[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson necks for you make
him feel at home they seem nice but
don't buy it it gets real gameofthrones
around here dude just mess around you
look at me and you're like why so dark
you're just able to foster kid you've
got it all if you could have one
superpower what would you think
everybody chooses flight you know why so
they can fly away from this conversation
little cuz heroes fly well you need your
fake family to stand up for you hey man
sorry about that
daily backs
I choose you
escapee
hello
say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
wait for you
okay Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah that's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing hey young set the field beam
dip it super straight you just can you
fly if I quit your veil I still
represent
if my quickness okay why are you talking
you know I don't think that's gonna buff
out your co-stars your phone charge help
make like a bad guy right
you have full immunity I will prove
you're dead sorry about your window
you're welcome for not getting robbed
okay stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]